what is the abuse of codependency you
could broadly say that narcissism hurts
other people and broadly say that
codependency hurts the codependent but
codependency actually meant somebody
who's an enabler of an alcoholic I just
wrote a book called a cult of one where
I redefined it back to the original
narcissus myth it was a beautiful Greek
Hunter who everybody loved but he
refused everybody but his counterpart in
ovid's version of this myth was called
Echo she was a wood nymph and she lost
her voice as she was cursed by the queen
of the gods so she could only Echo the
last three words that somebody spoke to
her she could no longer speak for
herself so I set up like a paradigm that
was you have narcissism which is
toxically Yang Echo codependency which
is toxically Yen they're always on
they're always talking it's all about
them that's toxic we're always off we're
always listening and it's all about
others that's toxic